in an increasingly dangerous world it is
vital to be able to protect yourself
from random attacks if you ever find
yourself in a situation where your
safety is threatened these are the top
10 tiniest self-defense gadgets that can
help you get out of a sticky situation
trailblazer firearms lifeguard as the
name suggests lifeguard is a handgun
designed to look just like a pack of
cards and can fit in your pocket with
ease but don't let its size fool you
this tiny gadget is not a toy at all it
can fire a single 0.22 lr caliber bullet
with enough stopping power to stop any
assailant dead in their tracks with a
thickness of 0.5 inches and a weight of
just 7 ounces lifeguard is a perfect
everyday carry firearm its folding
design allows it to be whipped out
quickly in case of an attack letting you
fire a single shot before it has to be
reloaded the life card utilizes the
finest materials in its construction
making this small self-defense handgun
extraordinarily durable and reliable at
just over three hundred you cannot beat
the trailblazer lifeguard as a
self-defense gadget many experts rate it
as a perfect alternative to carrying an
actual handgun for self-defense guard
dog diablo 2 tactical stun gun
flashlight part 320 lumen flashlight
part 5 million volt stun gun the guard
dog diablo 2 tactical stun gun
flashlight is a multi-functional
self-defense tool with solid stopping
power for a stun gun to be effective it
should deliver at least 1 million volts
this one packs five times that power so
it is strong enough to immobilize most
assailants unlike other stun guns this
one has a concealed stun technology that
leaves no visible probes allowing the
device to appear like a standard
flashlight this makes it perfect for
everyday use the flashlight comes with
three modes and has a built-in
rechargeable battery that eliminates the
hassle of replacing batteries it is made
out of an aircraft grade aluminum alloy
it also features an emergency glass
breaker bezel that can also double as a
blunt instrument for 33 the diablo ii is
a versatile yet not too crazy
self-defense weapon that you won't
regret carrying around with you saber 3
in 1 pepper spray a pepper spray is a
proven self-defense weapon the sabre
three-in-one pepper spray is an
excellent option for anyone seeking a
compact yet powerful can of pepper spray
to carry around for everyday use as it
is specifically designed to be used with
your existing keychain the saber comes
with a custom grip for better aim a
safety to prevent accidental discharge
and a quick release mechanism to quickly
detach it from your keychain when using
it in addition it contains an advanced
formula that includes cs tear gas
exposure to which can cause intense pain
in the eyes throat and nose plus the
spray also contains uv marking dye to
aid in suspect identification its 10
foot range is effective in self-defense
situations and the can is good for 25
bursts which is about 5 times more than
other brands this makes it perfect for
getting out of almost any sticky
situation with ease saber is an
industry-leading manufacturer of
defensive products and their pepper
sprays are used by law enforcement
officials all across the u.s so this 10
3 in 1 pepper spray is an absolute
must-have the fast strike whip the fast
strike self-defense whip is a small easy
to use weapon that can cause severe pain
when used correctly despite being
lightweight and compactly designed this
still delivers powerful force with its
flexible rubber coated steel cable from
afar or up close if you're lucky enough
for it to hit your opponent's
unprotected skin it can cause a lot of
damage the whip is malleable enough to
curl into your pocket the handle offers
plenty of grip thanks partly to how
similar they are aesthetically compared
to regular pocket knives it can fit
snugly into hands offering an excellent
balance without feeling too heavy on
either end it is perfect during crisis
situations where quick action must occur
because every second counts in a
self-defense situation the far strike
only costs just 22 dollars and thus it
is an incredibly cost effective
self-defense tool that will keep an
attacker at bay the gerber impromptu
tactical pen tactical pens are simple
self-defense gadgets that offer tons of
versatility making them an everyday
carry no brainer the gerber impromptu
tactical pen is made in america of
sturdy stainless steel before receiving
a serotoke coating which adds to its
durability while also adding some style
points the gerber impromptu tactical pen
can take on anything and any one you
throw at it this rugged writing
instrument comes equipped with an
integrated glass breaker tip so that you
can extricate yourself from any
threatening situation and just like any
other pen it comes with a pocket clip so
users will always have it close by in
case of emergencies despite all these
features it also performs flawlessly as
a pen even allowing you to take notes
during rainy conditions thanks to its
waterproof ink priced at just under 70
this pen is one badass self-defense
gadget worth having around you whether
for personal protection or tactical use
by law enforcement professionals this
pen can do it all she's birdie personal
safety alarm sometimes you don't need to
be aggressive in a self-defense
situation just drawing the attention of
others to the crime could be more than
enough to scare away any assailants this
is where she's birdie personal safety
alarm shines when activated it lets out
a 130 decibel alarm comparable to the
sound of a jet engine from 100 feet away
and that is definitely not a good place
to be the alarm also features a powerful
strobe light that flashes continually
along with the warning alarm this
combination of a loud alarm and a
powerful strobe is enough to disorient
an attacker providing you with a
diversion for a quick escape or alerting
others for help the birdie's modern and
minimalistic design allows you to make
it a permanent feature on your keychain
it's easy to use and the replaceable
batteries can last 40 minutes before
running out to activate the alarm all
you have to do is remove the top pin to
deactivate it put the pin back in priced
at just 20 dollars it is also highly
affordable this personal alarm can be a
perfect companion for anyone but it can
be especially beneficial for kids
differently abled people and those who
would not like to get into a physical
altercation monkey fist the monkey fist
is yet another tiny self-defense gadget
that can be carried along with you at
all times it's essentially a heavy metal
ball bearing wrapped inside a braided
paracord length it looks just like any
other accessory on a keychain to an
undiscerning eye but this unassuming
accessory can be used as a deadly
self-defense weapon if required it can
cause severe damage to your attacker
when swung with force thanks to the
metal ball a few good blows from the
monkey fist would be enough to deter
anyone plus the braided power cord
allows you to swing it like a whip from
a distance without you having to get
close to the assailant in order to
inflict damage prices of monkey fists
will depend on their size and length but
you can find an optimal one for under
twenty dollars munio kubatang keychain
designed in consultation with the
military and martial arts professionals
this is munio's latest generation of
kubatan style self-defense keychains
with this you don't have to worry about
any safety switches sprays or mechanical
failures when you need them the most
instead you can just use the pointed end
of this kubertan keychain to strike your
attacker anywhere in the body this can
lead to painful injuries enough to make
them think twice about messing with you
muno is one of the original designers of
this style of personal security
keychains and they constructed out of
virtually unbreakable abs plastic they
also offer a lifetime warranty on these
so you can be sure that you are
receiving an incredibly durable piece of
kit and at under 10
you cannot find a more practical
self-defense tool that can be carried
around by everyone everywhere sphere
self-defense ring defender ring sphere
is a minimalist everyday wear ring with
a smooth steel sphere on a steel ring
but there is more to this sleek ring
than meets the eye this smooth sphere
top can be quickly and discreetly
removed to reveal a sharp blade that can
inflict some severe damage to your
attacker they say a self-defense weapon
is only helpful if you happen to be
carrying it when you encounter trouble
well what's more convenient and harder
to leave home without than a ring so a
self-defense weapon discreetly
integrated into a daily wear ring is a
great solution the sphere is comfortable
enough to wear all day long and with its
non-threatening appearance nobody will
suspect a thing and since this is a
piece of jewelry defender rings have
developed an entire catalogue of
different designs so i'm sure that you
can find one that you like this
particular model the sphere is priced at
70 but you can also find other
self-defense rings that are a lot
cheaper surefire stiletto tactical
flashlight the last one on our list is
not your usual self-defense gadget but
it is an effective one if used correctly
the surefire stiletto tactical
flashlight is a high-powered 650 lumen
pocket led flashlight that can easily
slip into your everyday carry kit you
cannot use it to bludgeon your attacker
into submission but you can certainly
use its high-powered leds to blind and
disorient your attacker the stiletto
strikes an outstanding balance between
size weight and power plus its compact
flat design allows you to easily clip it
to your pocket or jacket for quick
retrieval it has three lighting modes
including a strobe feature that can be
pretty effective in a self-defense
scenario the stiletto costs 125 dollars
and comes with a built-in battery that
can be charged using a micro usb cable
it is also ipx7 rated so you can use it
in wet conditions without any worry hope
this list will help you make the right
choice for your next self-defense gadget
purchase for more awesome content click
a card on your screen and i'll see you
in the next video